there's a video apparently of people  discovering this very dramatic video  where they're doing the weigh-in and uh  and then they someone suspects that  there's weights in the fish they cut the  fish open which there's unfortunate for  the fish and so the fish get cut open  and they pull the weights out so they  actually put lead weights in the fish so  they could um win when they get to the  weigh-in now as an Avid Angler myself I  have to say that I'm totally disgusted  and disappointed that I never thought to  do this because that's that's actually  pretty smart it never even occurred to  me that you could put weights in the  fish's mouth to pump up your stats a  little bit  but it is bad it's cheating it brings  disgrace to those of us who enjoy  sitting around for hours at a time  stabbing hooks through fishes and mouths  for fun it makes us even look a little  bit weird  um which is to me what I am most angry  about